did you even know that Kate Winslet was
an avatar the way of water did courage
and spider's relationship feel forced he
is the dumbest things that happened in
the Avatar sequel
Avatar the way of water is stuck in a
strange limbo it's both a sequel picking
up where Avatar left off in a literal
sense but also clearly made with a
nostalgic Zeal to remind people of the
original think of the way the Jurassic
World movies feel more like Jurassic
Park theme park rides than actual
extensions of a coherent Story the
dumbest thing in the way of water that
we just have to live with is how it
shoehorns new roles for Sigourney Weaver
and Stephen Lang into the story even
though both of their characters died in
the first movie Weaver's new character
Kiri a child mysteriously born of the
Avatar of her original character Dr
Grace Augustine leads us some strange
Messianic qualities that are unique but
asking us to just roll with lying
psychotic Colonel courage being reborn
as a recombinant form of Avatar is a bit
much it retcons Avatar in the center the
technology to create a digital copy of a
human consciousness apparently existed
at the time and quarrych and his team
backed themselves up before the final
showdown so essential really like the
ill-fated ending of last the way of
water is asking us to invest in a world
where death has no meaning what Grace
Augustine and the other scientists are
also backed up that would certainly
explain why her Avatar is just hanging
around in her to tank for no discernible
purpose
the biggest criticism of the first
avatar is that Jake Sully is a classic
white savior it's tone deaf that way
that a complete stranger to the navi way
of life ends up uniting the tribes and
being chosen as torokamato you'd think
years later in the way of water since
shakers integrated more fully and that
half Navi children of natiri that this
would be less of a prevalent theme but
it seems Curie has been added to the
story as a second white Savior for the
price of one though raised as Navi she's
essentially a sort of reincarnated
version of Grace Augustine the other
most benevolent white person from the
first movie Kiri clearly has some chosen
one-type Powers Brewing that she
commutes with nature and can hear the
heartbeats of AWA the all mother not to
mention the way of water goes the same
route to Star Wars The Phantom Menace In
introducing the idea of Immaculate
Conception with a couple of casual
offhand remarks it's apparently a total
mystery how Grace Augustine's comatose
Avatar gave birth to a child although
the movie pools at a very disturbing
thread a couple of times as Kiri and
other characters wonder who her father
might be
there is something
really interesting going on in there
biologically
I would die to get samples
few sins of the original Avatar are as
unforgivable as unobtainium the precious
mineral that humans are on Pandora to
harvest fortunately no one utters that
ridiculous word in the way of water
although the reappearance of humanity is
abruptly handled we do learn early on
that they have a much more
straightforward and Urgent reason to
return to Pandora than getting rich that
is Earth is dying and Pandora is to be
entirely colonized as Humanity's new
home this creates a compelling Global
threat to all of the navi Clans that's
not even based on a bad plan but for the
two-thirds of the way through the way of
water we learned that an entirely brand
new magical substance like humanity is
after on Pandora it's a serum harvested
from the brains of giant sentient
whale-like creatures called Tolkien this
enzyme called amrite apparently stops
the aging process entirely in humans so
the hunting of tolkiens becomes another
lazy obvious allegory for the awful
colonizers not to respect sacred Navi
Traditions since the mechan hyena bomb
with the Tolkien and a half broken at
their loss the humans of course Harvest
just about a two liter soda bottle's
worth of amrite from a Tolkien the size
of a battleship and leave the rest to
right
were you even aware that the great Kate
Winslet is in this movie She provides
the voice of ronal the wife of the mech
kaina's leader and mostly glared's
disapprovingly at Jake and family for
endangering her tribe the way of water
introduces many new characters but not a
single one has the star power of Winslet
an Oscar winner and one of the greatest
actresses of her generation so it's a
bit dumb when you realize that like the
majority of characters in this
overstuffed movie she didn't have time
for any sort of character Arc or subplot
of her own what is likely she has a
bigger role to play in future
installments and doesn't make a bit part
in the way of water any less of a missed
opportunity other than mourning her soul
sister tolkien's death and being very
justifiably angry at the Sully's for
bringing destruction with them out to
the islands ronal barely registers this
is why K Winslet had to hold her breath
underwater for more than seven minutes
yes that's true probably the most
Preposterous running thread in avatar
The Way of water is the relation ship
between the recombinants colonel courage
and his long-lost CERN spider the kid is
the most prominent fully human character
left in a story having been left on
Pandora as a small child and raised with
the navi the way of water wants us to
buy into big plot points pivoting on the
burgeoning emotional bonds between this
child of Two Worlds and the lab-grown
Avatar of his deceased father the
problem with this is our courage in
either human or Avatar form is by far
the most one-dimensional character in
either movie he's nothing but a
murderous Soldier and the outright tells
spider that since he's technically a
form of Clone he's not actually his
father anyway sure correction spider may
have a few bonding moments while the
latter was being held hostage but it
really didn't go far enough then
seemingly out of nowhere courage is
suddenly concerned about spider when
natiri threatens his life and late
standoff spider then saves courage's
life which doesn't feel earned at all it
also doesn't even really matter because
presumably that humans could just keep
growing new courage three components and
redownloading his Consciousness anyway
James Cameron has an incredibly
successful career so perhaps he's earned
a little bit of self-referential leeway
but we have to bring into question the
sequence near the end of the way of
water where Star Crossed crushes low Arc
and Raya attempt to survive by
clambering around the outside of an
overturned ship and these moments are
pretty shamelessly close to the Beats
from Cameron's Titanic to the point that
it takes you out of the movie a little
bit it's already a bit much to ask us to
just roll with their romance which
lazily recreates the same beats as Jake
and the teary story in the first movie
just like his father lowark is a
stranger to the metsuke in a clan but
learns their ways and charms achieve's
daughter he also befriends a dangerous
and sacred animal that they Revere and
is told I See You by Reya in a direct
deco
alien that's all they see I see
during the sequence with a whaling
vessel slowly Turns Upside Down lowak
and Raya end up precariously perched
right on top of it as it submerges in
the water just like Jack and Rose in
Titanic they promise to hold on to each
other when they take the plunge what's
James Cameron up to
one of the strangest scenes in avatar
The Way of water is when Norman Max fly
out to the islands to try and see what's
going on with Kiri who had a seizure
while connected to the Mets keino
version of the spirit tree attaching
dios a machines to cure his head Nom
speculates that a spiritual connection
to awar may be a side effect of epilepsy
it's an Abrupt and strange suggestion
after lots of evidence that there may be
nothing special about Kiri at all this
flies in the face of the genuinely
faith-forward nature of both Avatar
movies and never gets followed up on in
general the spiritual purity of the navi
and the real world influence of awar is
empirically obvious in the first movie
the navi basically are losing the fight
until awe intervenes and possesses all
the animal life on the planet to attack
the human forces Avatar is a franchise
seems to have no interest in sincerely
exploring the delicate balance between
science and Faith this scene which
dabbles in skepticism just for the sake
of a distraction is one of the dumbest
things in the way of water
most people don't go to the movies to
read so subtitles can often be a deal
breaker when you're browsing the Netflix
menu as Jake said you learn the ways of
the Oma Takaya Clan of the navi and the
first Avatar the movie was committed to
showing both English and narvi being
spoken consistently and subtitling the
alien dialogue whenever necessary the
way language was treated was logical and
consistent but in the way of water
director James Cameron and Company must
have realized early on that since Jake
has now been living with a knob even
more than a decade they would
essentially be making a foreign language
film to solve this very early in the
sequel Jake tells us via voice over that
he's learned the navi language so
thoroughly that's when he hears it it
may as well be English and Presto
suddenly we also hear his children and
all other Navi speaking English when
Navi interact with other
English-speaking characters later
they're still subtitled but whenever
Navi are talking to each other it's all
English for convenience's sake it does
save the audience a lot of subtitle
reading but it's abrasingly dumb and an
elegant tweak to the rules of the way
the reality of what we're seeing it
being depicted after the earnest Pride
that the first avatar took him realizing
Navi culture it's kind of surprising
that the way of water just shrugs and
transforms 90 percent of potentially
Navi dialogue into plain old English
[Music]